Water, water, everywhere,
On all the moons a-freeze;
Please alien life say cheese.
Sup planetoids, thanks for watching DNews,
y’all know me.
I’m Trace.
We often hear, “We know more about space
than about the depths of our own oceans.”
Whether that’s true or not (and it’s arguable)
what about oceans on other planets?
What do we know about them?!
Firstly, Earth is the only planet anywhere
in the universe that we know has stable, liquid
water on its surface.
There are other celestial bodies we suspect
of having oceans though, like Europa and Ganymede,
moons of Jupiter, and Enceladus, a moon of
Saturn.
It’s just the oceans are trapped under sheets
of ice.
In fact, a new study in Geophysical Research
Letters from mid-2016 says tiny Enceladus
might have a rocky core, internal ocean, and
ice shell!
Using data from the Cassini probe, and seven
years of observations, scientists believe
under a (max) 22 kilometer-thick icy shell
sits a salty water ocean!
(Another paper says max 70 kilometers!).
They discovered this by looking at the wobble
of the moon as it orbits Saturn.
As the moon zoom the planet, the scientists
realized the planet’s wobble (called a libration)
appeared to move in such a way that could
only be explained if the icy surface wasn’t
connected to its core!
It’s almost as if the moon is sloshing like
a milk jug or bowl full of water!
That’s so COOL.
Not so cool that the ocean inside is frozen
through though, which is weird.
Out of the southern hemisphere of the moon,
scientists spotted over 100 “warm” geysers,
so they flew Cassini through them to sample
the mist -- it’s super salty WATER!
Here on Earth (the only model we have to go
by) life in the open ocean is rare -- so we
don’t yet know if there’s life under these
icy sheets…
We’ll have to design another probe to scoop
up the geyser mists without smashing any possible
life that exists inside!
But even with Enceladus’ ocean, Europa is
far more intriguing.
Europa is slightly smaller than our moon,
but larger than Pluto, and NASA believes Europa
has, like Earth, an iron core, a rocky mantle,
and a rocky “surface”… and on top of
that rocky “surface”?
An ocean of salty water!
Unlike Earth, but like Enceladus, Europa also
has a frozen icy crust and may have salty
water jets.
The reason Europa is more intriguing than
Enceladus?
Life needs three things: energy, water, and
heat.
In another study in Geophysical Research Letters,
scientists from NASA’s Jet Propulsion Laboratory
think judging by Europa’s neighbor Io, volcanic
activity may exist inside the icy crust of
the moon.
If so, it may mean both heat and nutrients
exist where the rocky crust meets the water
and there might be what’s called a redox
reaction -- or reduction and oxidation; a
chemical process that is similar to what we
have on Earth.
If this holds true, then the volcanic activity
brings heat and minerals and, of course, there’s
water…
SO.
LIFE, MOFO DO YOU SPEAK IT!
Europa, just might.
Look, it’s actually easier to launch a probe
to a moon in the outer solar system, or point
telescopes like the Hubble at a tiny moon
than it is to brave the depths of our own
oceans.
It seems to me, the more we learn about these
other moons (and exoplanets!) the more likely
we’ll understand oceans in general, and
hopefully we can infer more about our own
in the process.
What’s the difference between a moon and
a planet right?
Is there one?
Amy has the breakdown for you in this video
here.
Would you visit a moon?
Which one?
Ours?
Europa?
Phobos?
What’s your fav?
Let us know in the comments, please subscribe
for more DNews and thanks for watching.